[Música]
eu queria começar quando pra vocês uma
pequena fábula é a viúva floresta e lá e
tava tendo o incêndio é muito forte e os
animais estavam correndo desesperado de
todos os animais indo pra o lado
contrário do fogo fugindo muito
desespero e no meio dessa desse caos
todo o elefante percebeu que tinha um
beija-flor zinho bem pequenininho que
estava ainda despejar a água no incêndio
e ele ficava ainda no rio e no incêndio
no rio e no incêndio eo telefone para
perguntou pra ele beija foi até a rua
incêndio você quase não consegue
carregar você é muito pequenininho
porque você tá fazendo isso eo japão
falou é eu sou pequenininho mas eu tô
fazendo a minha parte
se você constatar um bem enorme viesse
me ajudar e todos animais depois de
também nós apagamos o incêndio em
minutos e o que eu quero contar pra
vocês
hoje é a história de beija-flores da
vida real
no canadá há jovens criaram unidades de
cultivo onde até mesmo as regiões mais
frias
as pessoas conseguem implantar dentro
delas e ter acesso a alimento garantir
segurança alimentar além de um modelo de
negócios firme na alemanha jovens
criaram através de impressoras 3d
membros para amputados criaram um
sistema modelo de negócio pra
deficientes mentais através da
reutilização de sabonetinho de hotel na
índia eles desenvolveram o sistema de
banheiros comunitários garantindo que as
pessoas pudessem é de ficar em condições
adequadas garantindo saneamento e menos
doenças
a nigéria eles criaram escolas para
crianças refugiadas e o mundo
ele negócio para os pais essas mesmas
crianças para que elas não tivessem que
trabalhar com eles
no brasil jovens criaram a primeira
cooperativa para deficientes mentais do
brasil
eu tenho que contar pra vocês um pouco a
história da minha vida de como foi que
eu entrei nessa vida de beija flor
então quando eu saí de ensino médio
eu tenho que escolher uma carreira para
seguir e eu tinha certeza que ela evoca
as senhoras e publicitária então que foi
que eu fiz aqui mas ela só tem faculdade
particular e eu juntei todas as minhas
economias da vida inteira
minha família era contra não queria
pagar etc para e aí eu paguei a
matrícula ea primeira mensalidade
e eu fui comecei a cursar o dinheiro
acabou e não tinha dinheiro pra segunda
mensalidade
e aí aconteceu e teve que sair do curso
porque minha família ainda não apoiá lo
e quando eu saí eu fui para um cursinho
e todo mundo sabe que com senhoras você
está lá e não faz a mínima ideia do que
você realmente quer ea minha família
sempre a faz algo na saúde que você vai
ter segurança estabilidade e etc
eu fiz eu não tenho muito a ver com isso
mas eu vou tentar nutrição que é
interessante e aí eu entrei no primeiro
período e nutrição eu me envolvi
conselho acadêmico projeto de pesquisa e
extensão
vivendo para a faculdade chegava sete da
manhã saí às sete horas da noite e vivia
por aquilo e eu estava amando eu estava
roubando está uma traição
e aí quando chegou nas férias eu fiz eu
quero fazer um projeto social em outro
país eu quero ver a pobreza por outro
lado porque quando fazia projetos de
pesquisa e extensão com nutrição eu
conhecia pobreza que eu não sabia que
existia em maceió
a gente sempre vê reportagens caótica as
coisas tristes mas sobre o nosso estado
mas pra mim era algo muito distante
eu nunca vi uma tragédia de perto e
quando entrei em contato com a nutrição
com isso a nutrição pode oferecer
eu me sinto totalmente conectada pelo
lado social eu queria fazer uma mudança
por maceió e aí com esse pensamento eu
fui fazer um intercâmbio social na gente
eu queria conhecer a pobreza de outro
lugar
e aí quando eu quando eu fui para a
argentina eu tive uma experiência
incrível
vi a pobreza de outro de outra forma ou
de outro ângulo quero que eu realmente
queria viver lá e isso mudou minha vida
eu continuei me sentindo totalmente
feliz e encantado pela nutrição
até que um dia um amigo me perguntou o
que quer fazer com que se formar e aí
comecei a fazer aquela lixo eu quero
fazer uma ong para os abrigados eu quero
trabalhar numa multinacional eu quero
ter um rosto e roubar eu quero fazer uma
série de coisas e ele fez a pergunta
mais óbvia
então por que você passou três anos
e aí como quem responde sem nem saber o
que está dizendo eu disse porque minha
mãe mandou e quando eu disse isso foi
como se eu mesmo tivesse me dado uma
facada eu fiquei muito triste voltei pra
casa eu chorei e chorei chorei chorei
chorei chorei até a mãe chegava do
trabalho quando ela chegou eu disse pra
ela
mãe eu preciso mudar de curso ou eu vou
ser pobre infeliz pra sempre e é mãe
teve certeza ela quer fazer medicina
agora ea história foi outra porque eu
acordei no outro dia depois de todo esse
caos de toda essa desconstrução eu
acordei eu quero fazer a administração
como se fosse algo que já tivesse dentro
de mim eu soubesse há muito tempo e aí
nesse mesmo período que eu planejei tudo
para mudar de curso eu fui convidada
para algo sensacional algo que me vencem
e beija flor e o que foi eu fui
convidada para a formação da enatur do
fao ea proposta que me fizeram um
convite foi de fazer projetos sociais
empreendedores sustentáveis que causasse
impacto econômico e mudar serve duas
pessoas e como desde a nutrição desde o
primeiro período aqui a certeza eu
queria ser beija flor
eu tive certeza que eu tinha que entrar
nisso aí então nós começamos o nosso
primeiro projeto viva que significa a
forma de como a natureza o projeto viva
ele funciona a copa
times de recicladores de lixo urbano
aqui de maceió e nós trabalhamos lá com
gestão financeira gestão de recursos
humanos gestão de produção além de toda
a questão física da cooperativa para que
os cooperados tivessem condições mais
dignas dignas de trabalho e esse projeto
ele foi sensacional mas o mais incrível
dessa história inteira é que renato
sophal ela tem 36 beija flores
aqui em alagoas mas quando tiver o
brasil são 3 mil beija-flores e 92
instituições de ensino superior no mundo
são 70 mil estudantes e mais de 1700
instituições de ensino superior em 36
países
todos juntos fazem o impacto alcançam 1
milhão de pessoas e que renato significa
renato significa o nosso propósito que
nós acreditamos e nós acreditamos que a
ação empreendedora para os outros cria
um mundo melhor para todos nós e é
realmente isso que eu vivi campeonatos
mas quando falo de números de alcance e
impacto parece que esses jovens fazem
coisas extremamente grandiosas eles
estão revolucionando o sistema estão
criando um modelo de negócios nunca
pensado antes e realmente isso que esses
jovens estão fazendo mas o mais
fantástico de tudo é que tudo parte de
uma simples idéia de deus de empatia e
pensamento de como eu posso mudar
realidades e eu vou contar um pouco pra
vocês de um projeto que está sendo
desenvolvido agora mesmo aqui em maceió
é esse projeto vem da comunidade gama
leis
nessa comunidade algumas pessoas são
muito pobres e elas não têm acesso à
alimentação de qualidade e aí as
crianças elas têm uma estatura e o
diâmetro do cérebro menor que a média
eles é algo assustador
essas crianças elas comem todos os dias
elas se alimentam todos os dias mas como
nós podemos chamar se não fomente quando
uma pessoa morre ou têm doenças por
carências alimentares porque ela só tem
acesso a um tipo de nutriente e aí nesse
projeto objetivo que está
o que está sendo feito agora é o
desenvolvimento de um modelo de negócios
através de hortas hidropônicas que serão
criadas já que a nintendo assim que as
pessoas relatem uma nova fonte de renda
e têm uma alimentação de qualidade e
acesso nutrientes é o mais vantagem por
isso tudo o que é mas é incrível é que
são micro ações
esses jovens eles já nasceram sabendo
fazer hortas hidropônicas eles não
nasceram sabendo fazer o escoamento de
produtos e eles também não fazem
faculdade que ensine eles a fazer isso
mas eles têm uma coisa muito importante
que é a motivação
eles querem fazer isso acontecer eles
querem mudar a vida dessas pessoas
então todos os dias eles vão descobrir
qual é o próximo passo para alcançar
esse objetivo são micro ações para
alcançar algo grande
então eles procuraram alguém que pudesse
ensinar eles visitaram a comunidade
criar um lançamento com os líderes passo
a passo a passo eles vão conseguir mudar
a vida de crianças e garantir que elas
tenham a estatura eo tamanho do cérebro
do do crânio adequado para a idade delas
o quão fantástico é isso é o projeto
viva o que eu falei anteriormente ele
com apenas cinco meses de criação foi
levado para o campeonato nacional da
nota do brasil e esse campeonato é algo
que me deixa muito feliz se lembrar dele
aqui hoje é porque nesse palco nós
fizemos eventos para arrecadar fundos
para poder atendê lo porque foi em
fortaleza
e nesse campeonato a inatos do fal
ganhou o prêmio de revelação do ano
o projeto rival foi premiado como um dos
10 maiores projetos de brasil e eu fui
premiado a líder estudantil do ano e com
essa premiação eu pude entender e
atender ao maior evento de
empreendedorismo social aniversário do
mundo que a copa do mundo daí natas e
como se já não fosse fantástico e fui
convidada para ser embaixadora da onu
pela meta desenvolvimento sustentável
número 5 e eu pude
ministrar fóruns e participar das
sessões falando com pessoas da áfrica do
canadá da europa de todos os lugares do
mundo sobre igualdade de gênero e
diversos outros assuntos e já sem dúvida
foi uma experiência que mudou minha vida
o que eu queria deixar para vocês hoje é
que quando você é um beija-flor sozinho
você pode pensar que não vai dar muito
certo mas algo que eu aprendi e aprendo
todo dia da minha vida é que tem vários
beija-flores pelo mundo e todos eles
estão se esforçando para fazer o impacto
e uma coisa mais importante do que
existirem vários beija-flores pelo mundo
é que existem várias pessoas do mundo em
todas essas pessoas têm potencial de se
tornarem beija flor
todos nós podemos ser beija flores
obrigada
[Aplausos]